ти сьогодні чомусь хотів би повністю
підтвердить захід нас скликаю
вибухаючи vs
телекомпанія вигляд представляє та але я вам
все дам я в самій правда не знаю
стояти в астралі дасть українці всю
необхідну танки чи такі протилежні
шинку брону письменник до зубного методу
україни сальто truchen путінський режим
його не zara спробуєш фірма вий торт
моєї мами і називає macron рецепт
такі самі як наполеон i came крони до
розвіяти
спробуємо
[музика]
навіть мама
не
[музика]
можу навіть що всім христос вас фарбу
ремені слуцис іранські при заданих з
проблем дуже легко номери я приїхав
цвірінькнув часто цвіркнув вас все
[музика]
[оплески]
це росія життя за час його правління
22 роки став кращим
звичайно абсолютно а що покращилася
ніколи
завжди
я не можу це все висловити, але не вмію
загалом-то в загальному плані я тільки за
тільки не будемо
вас не ходимо ніжками дрібниці копієчка
схожий на
голос африці має бути почутий
виступав і
президент
казахстану
така і
дякую шановні торкаємося моделі вич
камільович така
[музика]
так це безпілотник
там
[музика]
[ __ ] такі справи чуваки такі справи
нпз жку повторі
ну та з того боку веселий
[музика]
ми
дружба
у лева
turbo
j
це стало виглядом навпомацки від насті закладі
Макдональдс відкрилася наново на росії
за новим ребрендингом до нових
навколо та й . ось ще пара голодувати і
смачно біцепса
смачного біцепса
он і ясна хоче видно живота з виду
снує брендом антонович зацінити їх
але викладатись і якщо ти фанат
подумають про тебе сподобається чи ти
дивишся вигляд терпіти куща і . ми
пропонуємо багато знайомих позицій зміню
таких я шматок кілограмовий бургер з
молочним квадратом картопляна стружка
кімнатною температурою смажені в
фритюрі пташиний кубики з хрусткою
зрадник тобто бутерброд з куркою
також молочний облогу якщо ви побачите
зниклого кровно рональда Макдональда
дзвонити в поліцію смак та й . час ви
полюбіть це
ви полюбите c
[оплески]
[музика]
і
вона
[музика]
зайчик
так
ти себе сама
коли тебе
[музика]
їх сумний
рекорд тисяч знову це було диво я
намажу помилку взяти ча те хен і вдихай
буду кашею 3 та суду 3 секунди вона роками
то заарештувати що це без рубав ми
зараз нижніми переплутала так божевільний а
я його продовжуючому давайте так не здаюся
і живи не з рука мінуса подружить річка
все буде добре на wear my money іван та я
так чи всі пряма пісня продаєте з
решти вчених інфо проти
таку зол of our 100 разів потрапив
побачили ось це [ __ ] не поїхав такого
саме ганчіркою статевого у нас у місті я
вирішив їх знаходимо а нам тут треба зняли
По-чоловічому
солі на її принципі вона тільки для
цього завгодно кудись он туди її треба
викинути тому що на [ __ ] на нас тут
потрібна така ганчина полетіла
купівля вами території вся Україна
забувайте ще сун їх налагодиться, а то
демілітаризація
окупанти курить не палити ваше місто
бальцер одне прискорити та окупанти палити
ногу та ваш корабель
прискорити ваш корабель з гори
адже не знаю як реагувати на це все
виживеш
не повернусь
через п'ять хвилин у вас не було танків
якихось там стояв ти теж не стріляв
ось є
[музика]
втратив їдемо все за нас розумним
на навчання здалося що спереду
як з автомата застава за нашими
позиціям.
[музика]
або нічого собі
швидкістю вони себе як метеор не тобі
здрасті
двері батик тупо ми їх берців на
що ти пиздиш [ __ ] своє закрий на ви
тупо тип моїх герцях викуповує та [ __ ]
береться тіла [ __ ] [ __ ] все блейза
рівних берців на
поляниця
я не після поляниці
вулиця до гурманію по-особі павич
по
пост вже по
а-ля
не
я а я
поляниця
[музика]
прошу теж хочу знати їх напів нитки
Поляниці можна назад пробачити мене
шеннон ще так я за люд чим може він і
люди а за google і не прийдуть і починай
якщо купувати може бути наведено слова але
сказати биту таким, а ти почитай кобзаря
поранити їх астани горі pascal
супниця а
закрий та
українці
за цих умов видавала громадянство
україни росія на
губи тут не
дістати і балтики мені треба ще
придадуться він ще не сильно ржавому
[музика]
[оплески]
складності ми з вами назбирали близько 40
тисяч рублів
[сміх]
українці вузлі schools падінням економіка
на тлі війни вважав із барівати свої
лікарі у банку харкова
експерти для душа наділена там є вісь
х і ось це дуже але по ріверу послуги
на цех двох банках лежати мільйон гри ви
пісні кроки конверту особисто 3 photoshop та
цієї ціни тип то склеювання мечеть на плечі
нам поки ти дуже видно незабаром майбутньому
бензину купили планети рахунок парі сили
типу ти псих russkaja божена тонна
бетону щоб забору вати назад димус
кави та деталі взводом а для того щоб
noble зад і смерть російських у губ
антифризу роздаєте на 3 байрактори і для
і url дуже Сергій притулила байрактор все
могутній ваньків more lada kalina
ви просто вдумайтесь
місяць тому і втримав і в інтернеті ставок
з чпу з брат єврошина байрактор і
за раз
лачин і притулку підіймаюсь на повному
серйозно на байрактор і топ то скоро
волонтери будуть кубат та бойову техніку
ви є щоб рушайте не знаю
там через рід
притула такі значні смухлів художники
солити ми коротше замахав осям і ви
вирішили купити і на той вид вигляд критим і
хочемо закриті нема
[музика]